did anyone try to talk you out of making
this film my accountant
okay aside from your accountant okay no
one said don't don't go down this rabbit
hole don't the opposite okay the
opposite you know it's like some things
are kind of self-evident you know I
think for me I'm interested in subjects
that are irrelevant to our world that
are happening now that have an impact on
on all of us
so I was seeing this having a tremendous
impact plus I'm really interested in the
way that the media impacts our lives
I've always been really fascinated with
that do you think you could have worked
for the National Enquirer say 1980s
1990s so funny when the film premiered
in LA a few weeks ago a couple of these
Enquirer reporters were there on stage
with me and one of them we know were and
said you know mark would have made an
amazing Inquirer reporter and Amy
Nicholson knew who is our moderator I
mean and she said so mark would you have
would you have been interested in being
an inquiry reporter and the answer is no
I wouldn't have I think that it's a real
Faustian bargain to take that job you
are trading a lot of your own ethics
really for that job
I like aspects of what they did I
I really believe in holding truth to
power I really believe that people who
do things that are unethical
who are in the public eye should should
be exposed I think that I don't have any
problem with that
so some of the things they did I think
were great in terms of that certainly
the reporting they did in the OJ case
the john edwards situation those were
things that i think were in the realm of
i'd say good good reporting but for the
most part it's just been i think
something that has helped to create
journalism and it
the public's understanding of what is a
fact and what is not a fact and that's
dangerous so no I wouldn't have been
interested in being a part of that had
you heard the term catch and kill before
before we started the film actually
working on the film in earnest I hadn't
heard the term catch and kill because
the first time I heard the term catch
and kill was when I read Ronin Pharaohs
article in it was April of 2018 about
Karen McDougal and that was when that
was the first time that I'd heard about
it that's the first time that I think it
started to get introduced into the news
media in a big way in making the film
before that like we were shooting before
that all came out which was wild that
was kind of freakish that we were out in
the world filming The Enquirer and then
this big revelation called catch and
kill happens that the timing of that was
really unusual but what we were learning
on the field from these old-time
Enquirer reporters like no we never
heard of the word catching killer the
term catch and kill before we always
called it trade outs like okay we have
some really sketchy information about
this celebrity you know Bob Hope for
example and so we're gonna present that
information to mr. hopes team his
publicist his lawyer his agent whatever
it is and then in exchange for not
running that story he's gonna Troy
they're gonna trade out for a story
about Christmas at home with the hopes
or a ride on the golf course with you
know and they did this for all of the
major celebrities so you know you can
imagine how much dirt they acquired
decade after decade of doing that kind
of a practice but they called it trade
outs they didn't call it catch and kill
catch and kill was something that I
first heard of through Ronan Pharaoh's
reporting and then they were also by the
way his book is fantastic okay yeah and
you have him in the film as well briefly
okay yeah our kind of job and then there
were also where they would purchase the
rights to a story and sit on it
was that like another form of catching
kill innocence because then that story
sort of was taken out of the hands of
individual yep that happened in in a
number of instances and in the film
there's there's a number of anecdotes
that that go into that and that's a very
disturbing practice because a celebrity
has been caught in the act of doing
something really heinous and often times
it was celebrities who would go on to do
things much worse down the line and so
you have to wonder had those stories
come to light back then and not been
buried would the with the behavior that
happened later have happened and that's
that's where I think the story gets
really chilling does the public have a
right to know everything about
celebrities in your opinion after having
done this film you know there's like
several camps on that some people think
once you get into the public eye your
life your secrets are no longer your own
the public owns you in some sense I
don't believe that I don't believe that
I mean you know why should that be the
case I I think that a lot of a lot of
gossip reporters a lot of tabloid
reporters use that I think to go to
sleep at night and look at themselves in
the mirror but I don't believe that just
because somebody is entertaining us or
compelling us with a great performance
or you know engaging us with incredible
music or whatever it is that they're
doing that we're entitled to know
everything about them I think that
that's I just don't think that that's
right and I think that the truth is is
that it's a business and that there are
benefits that celebrities and creative
professionals artists musicians get from
being in tabloids they get publicity
their permit they get to Brod films
people buy into their image they buy
into the narrative but I think this kind
of ruthless pursuit of people you know
hounding them with paparazzi hounding
their children I don't I don't see the
point I think that's just more about a
sickness in our culture you know this
obsession with wanting to know
everything about other people this
comparison compare and despair
you know and that's that's that's a
larger issue well one part that was
especially chilling in the film for me
was when one of the reporters or maybe
two talked about how it was actual
family members not not just disgruntled
employees of a celebrity or a politician
that called in tips but actually like
family members and supposed friends and
it was really based on jealousy
I was just that was that was sort of
like a real gut reaction and and just I
don't know what are your thoughts on
that I miss you far I was fascinated
with how many people would sell would
sell people out you know that was people
ask me like what's the what are some of
the most interesting things that you
discovered in making the film one of the
most interesting things was the lengths
to which these Enquirer reporters would
go to get sources around famous people
so like nurses who were checking people
into hospitals valets maitre d's at
restaurants waiters at restaurants
barbers beauticians but also close
family members you know disgruntled
lovers the sister that is not that's the
black sheep of the family a child
whatever it is all these people were on
the Enquirer payroll so you know I don't
think it's any different today but it is
pretty chilling when you realize that
you know you get famous you get rich you
get powerful and there is a price to pay
for that and then you become susceptible
to people selling you out
was there one thing that was a huge
eye-opener for you in doing this film
and I think you know what's so what's so
interesting the I think the the the
number of people involved in gathering
negative stories are up about the rich
the famous and the powerful and then
brokering those stories to curry favor
or whatever they're doing whatever
reason it is why they would take a
negative story and keep it and then you
know that that network was really
eye-opening the fact that that exists
and not just in the Inquirer
on a much broader level you know
somebody in our film says you know that
there are thousands of these deals made
every day to protect the rich and
powerful that's that's pretty
eye-opening that's a very sobering
thought you know that if you have money
and you are in a position of power in
the country and the culture that you can
use those resources to maintain a bright
and shiny image and I think making this
film made all of us very aware of just
how often that happens sure wasn't Orson
Welles who had numerous things that were
thrown at him for the movie that he did
from powerful family that wanted to
silence him yeah a powerful family in
the news business right yeah you know
you make a film like that naturally
there's gonna be backlash I think there
was someone who warned him like don't go
to that hotel room there's there's a
story waiting to happen there you know
so yeah that's happened since the guy
from touch of evil is in that hotel room
don't go in there
you